avec nous pour en parler anouar kbibech
vice-président du cfcm président du
rassemblement des musulmans de france
l'une des huit associations qui
composent le cfcm bonsoir à vous à noir
kbibech vous êtes en direct par
téléphone eric diard député les
républicains des bouches du rhône
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être là
alors emmanuel macron qui a donc laissé
quinze jours à eau non signataires pour
clarifier leur position bientôt une
semaine de passer toujours en rien
silence radio certains dénoncent une
fracture au sein du conseil français du
culte musulman avant de réagir je vous
propose de regarder le tweet du
journaliste franco algérien à mohamed
sifaoui deux associations islamistes
turques le ccmtf emilie gourd us ainsi
que foi et pratique signe un communiqué
pour dire qu'elle rejette la charte des
principes pour un islam de france
cette clarification idéologique doit
impliquer leur exclusion du cfcm kbibech
ouyahia véritablement une césure vous
êtes conscients les frondeurs entre
nîmes et vont rentrer dans le rang et
signés non il ne faut pas dramatiser les
choses nous avons mené depuis le 18
février pendant le 18 novembre quand le
président de la république nous a reçus
pour lui présenter les documents
déclaratif et constitutif du conseil
national des villes
nous avons acté le principe de la mise
au point des sharks étaient principes
républicains et une charte des principes
de l'islam de france
nous y avons travaillé depuis deux mois
il y avait pratiquement un consensus sur
l'ensemble des principes figurent sur
serge cette charte
par contre il ya un certain nombre de
fournir à sion sur lesquels les trois
fédérations qui n'ont pas signé pour le
moment souhaité prendre un peu plus de
temps pour consulter leurs instances
respectives et pour le moment
manifestement ces formulations le rose
encore problème mais j'espère que dans
les prochains jours un situation se
débloquera et qu'on relancera le
processus de création du conseil
national des imams qui a mené 1
les dimanches et à les accompagner en
termes de formation et de travail sur
leur statut alors dans leur a
effectivement du fond de ce qui les
empêche de signer parce que les
désaccords sont tous même profond pour
certains qu'on a pu d'ailleurs avoir sur
notre antenne
côté politique eric diard marine le pen
s'est emparé de ce sujet écoutez ce
tweet nière de la patronne du
rassemblement national
alors le gouvernement doit procéder à
leur dissolution
marine le pen c'est courant qui
demandent la dissolution tout simplement
de du cfcm créé par nicolas sarkozy en
2003 la question de fond c'est cela il
faut tout simplement supprimée cet
instant selon vous est il ya moi je vous
dirais mais pour m quoi il faut pas
oublier que cette instance
il faut bien n'a aucune aucun pouvoir
coercitif évidemment sur les différentes
mouvances premièrement deuxièmement
c'est un organe de concertation et qui
rassemble donc les différentes mouvances
de suisse l'âme
on pourrait dissoudre mais pour le
remplacer par quoi aujourd'hui il n'y a
rien mais nous avons je suis orateurs
dont vous savez la commission spéciale
sur la loi qui renforce les principes
républicains la semaine dernière nous
avons auditionné le président du conseil
du culte musulman je lui posais la
question justement par rapport à ce
qu'avait dit monsieur sifaoui dans le
jdd puisqu'il y avait eu trois mouvances
qui avait claqué la porte
aujourd'hui il y en a une ça change et
je crois que musulmans de france
vous êtes vous avez signé maintenant
vous avez signé la charte
mais bon il était assez pessimiste sur
la temps l'entente parce que quand même
il faut pas oublier que de le il y a
quand même des premières mentant sur
internent je les sentais déjà entre le
recteur la grande mosquée et le
président et le président et il ya aussi
les aime
solans étrangères qui n'arrange pas du
tout anouar kbibech il n'est pas là nos
fonds du problème justement ces
influences étrangères
on rappelle l'un des enjeux est le plus
sensible certainement de cette charte
c'est la création d'un conseil national
des imams qui sera chargée de entre
guillemets labelliser les imams exerçant
en france précisément quand on sait que
ces fédérations sont financés par les
pays étrangers il ya ce conflit
d'intérêts ce que c'est pas là justement
le problème de fond déjà une petite
précision moi je suis le président du
rassemblement des musulmans de france
ils n'ont de visuellement de france et
je suis ancien président du csl est donc
à ce titre en tant que président du rmf
nous avons contribué à l'élaboration de
cette charte est parmi les points
essentiels dans cette charte c'est le
refus de l'ingérence étrangère dans la
gestion des pays musulmans en france et
l'ensemble des fédérations composant le
cfcm sont d'accord sur ce principe
maintenant le fait qu'il y ait cinq
fédérations qui ont signé et 3 qui
prenne un peu de temps pour le faire ne
remet pas en cause le fait qu'il ya
unanimité de la part de tous et des
fédérations pour rejeter le linge et les
ingérences étrangères
rejetée l'islam politique en faisant de
la religion et non de la politique et
pour affirmer que les valeurs de l'islam
sont totalement compatibles avec les
valeurs et les lois de la république et
c'est ça l'essence même de cette charte
des principes de l'islam de france est
et c'est bien comme ça anouar kbibech
chaque qu'on vous avait présenté à
l'instant et que vous êtes présenté sur
notre antenne n'y a pas eu d'erreur sur
ce point effectivement mais c'est vrai
monsieur vient parler de musulmans de
france ont soif de soi un mois donc lula
pour que ce que très bien très bien
eric diard est-ce que selon vous vous
qui connaissez effectivement vous l'avez
rappelé très bien ce sujet est ce que
les musulmans de france se reconnaissent
alors il faudra peut-être leur pose est
évidemment la question à eux mais est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment d'être
reconnaissent dans cet organisme côté je
ne suis pas
le mieux placé pour le dire je ne peux
pas répondre à cette question
moi je pense que malheureusement le plus
grand ennemi des musulmans c'est l'islam
politique c'est le fondamentalisme après
moi je vais vous poser une question
puisque vous êtes quand même un des
pères fondateurs j'allais dire de ce
conseil est ce que toutes les mouvances
rejette la peau stasi c'est à dire et
c'est à dire que ne considère plus la
peau stasi quand même crime
est ce que toutes les mouvances condamne
l'homophobie l'antisémitisme et prône
également l'égalité hommes-femmes ça
c'est ma question je sais que c'est
votre cas mais je pose la question pour
les mouvances qui justement ne sont pas
signataires
mais justement le fait de ratifier ce
que cette charte et devrait être j'irais
là la preuve que l'ensemble de ses
composantes du cfcm avait à ses
principes et notre souhait c'est que
dans quelques jours toutes les
fédérations qui composent le csr se
retrouvent autour de ces valeurs qui
sont affirmer haut et fort dans cette
charte et qui sont écrit noir sur blanc
le rejet de toute forme de
discrimination sur tout à un certain
nombre de critères l'attachement à
l'égalité notamment l'égalité enfin le
rejet de toute forme de racisme que ce
soient les actes anti-musulmans les
actes antisémites et toute forme de
racisme et des discriminations
ce sont des valeurs fortes qui sont
proclamés dans cette charte est
justement c'est un acte fondateur dont à
la fois la refondation des relations
entre le culte musulman en france et les
pouvoirs publics mais également et la
république surtout est également un acte
fondateur auprès de l'ensemble de nos
compatriotes de confession musulmane ou
qu'ils adhèrent à ces valeurs-là et
qu'il est il qu'ils assurent leur
promotion pour renforcer le vivre
ensemble
je vais vous faire réagir sur cette
réaction de tareq oubrou à le grand imam
de bordeaux qui s'est exprimé sur cette
écoute et c'est dommage que le csm
produit ce texte sous la pression
politique alors qu'il aurait dû prendre
l'initiative par lui-même
le conseil français du culte musulman
aurait dû déclarer théologiquement
parlant la compatibilité des valeurs de
l'islam avec les lois de la république
et lumière c'est souvent le reproche qui
est fait ce texte a été produit sous la
pression de l'exécutif
vous êtes d'accord sous la pression
aussi parce qu'il y avait ce test qui
arrivent et regarder en avant
comme par hasard il a été signé dimanche
alors que que l'étude en commission
commencé dès le lundi à mon avis il ya
une pression mais moi je suis quand même
inquiet parce que j'ai écouté le
président moussaoui attentive à manger
je vous écoute et guay et gégé écouter
également mohamed sifaoui
il ya certains mouvements
fondamentalistes qui ne reconnaissent
pas certaines valeurs de la république
et c'est pour cela il me semble qu'ils
ne veulent pas signer cette charte
anouar kbibech justement le cfcm qui
aurait dû prendre selon l'imam de
bordeaux
l'initiative par lui même c'était la
meilleure solution pour justement qu'il
n'y ait pas discussion et c'est fini
ciotti veut la lectrice par les
musulmans et par le ca sion depuis les
années conduit président du csl de 2015
à 2017 il ya déjà une charte des imams
qui a été élaboré à l'initiative
exclusive du c'est excellent il a été
généralisée à l'ensemble des régions de
france à travers les crcm les
conseillers régionaux du culte musulman
cette fois on va encore plus loin par la
mise en place d'une nouvelle instance
qui le conseil national des imams qui
est composé à moitié d'un collège des
président du csm et à moitié par un
collège des imams référents de chaque
fédération donc c'est une étape
supplémentaire et le fait de deux de le
doter de cette charte des principes
devraient pouvoir s'y fier et clarifier
les relations entre le culte musulman en
france et la république et je pense que
ce qui s'est passé lundi à l'elysée avec
la signature solennelle de cette charte
par cinq fédérations sur les huit qui
composent le csn est un acte fondateur
importants historiques qui est du même
niveau que que l'accord qui a été trouvé
par napoléon bonaparte en 1807 avec les
représentants du culte
il se rallie donc il faut pas minimiser
cet acte il se passe un peu dans la
difficulté dans la mesure certains
fédération souhaite avoir un peu plus de
temps pour judy gréer faire adopter les
formulations qui se trouvent dans cette
charte par leurs instances
il faut donner du temps au temps comme
envié dans quelques jours j'espère que
nous nous retrouverons tout ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure pour constituer ce
conseiller national daily matinée
exclura personnes aux avait cité tout à
l'heure caréco gros tarés corot est une
référence et une respectable et animale
qui a sa place dans le paysage actuel en
france et le conseiller national des
imans aura les meilleures relations avec
des imans comme le grand imam de
bordeaux
merci en tout cas merci en tout cas à
tous les deux noirs au québec chez erika
d'avoir accepté ce débat merci